donc en quelques mots je suis fille est
donc pdg cofondateur d'une entreprise
qui s'appelle terrain nexus qui est un
essaimage du commissariat à l'énergie
atomique comme comme souvent dans le
domaine de la high tech
ce sont des solutions qui sont issus de
la sphère académique qui sont ensuite
passés dans la sphère privée à travers
la création de start up et donc j'en
suis le pur produit du transfert de
technocrates et dans le dôme du passage
de l'académique vers le privé j'étais
moi même chercheur au cea et je suis
également président de france biotech
allende et président de france biotech
au sein de france biotech j'animais un
groupe de travail que je continue à
animer sur les partenariats public privé
dans le domaine de la santé qui est
devenu un observatoire du transfert de
techno et donc france biotech en
quelques mots donc c'est une association
qui a maintenant 20 ans d'existence qui
anime écosystèmes et entrepreneurs de la
ftq
même si ça s'appelle france biotech on a
aujourd'hui parmi nos adhérents des
biotech des medtechs et des solutions de
e-santé en france pour information vous
avez environ 2000 entreprises de ce
secteur avec à peu près 800 biotech un
peu plus d'un millier de sociétés qui
développent des dispositifs médicaux et
le reste en santé avec comme vous
l'imaginez avec tout ce qui était les
consultations utilisation de la santé
digital une forte croissance sur les
solutions de e-santé ont créé environ 60
entreprises dans ce domaine par an avec
évidemment comme je voulais indiqué pas
mal de start up qui sont créés à travers
les offices de transfert de technologie
que ce soit les sacs soit inserm
transfert que ce soit le cea et donc
voilà le les simplement planté quelques
éléments de décor avant qu'on commence
l'audition merci beaucoup en tout cas de
nous donner cette opportunité pour
s'élever sur les schémas nombre jours à
tous et je suis le délégué général de
france biotech donc j'anime la structure
france biotech au quotidien aux côtés du
président et du conseil d'administration
de france biotech
mais sur le gréement masque c'est bon ok
non je ne vous entendez par franck
grimaud donc directeur général de vale
va donc c'est une société qui est
spécialisé dans le domaine du vaccin qui
est issu de la fusion entre une société
que j'ai créée il ya vingt ans vivalis
est une société autrichienne intercell
donc on a formé voilà un nouveau pure
player dans le domaine du vaccin on
commercialise des vaccins en particulier
dans le domaine du voyage
on a en développement le premier vaccin
contre la maladie de lyme conte dont on
va finaliser le développement et les
files heures on est les premiers à voir
un vaccin chikungunya qui ont laissé
faire voire entrée sur le marché en 2023
puis évidemment vous le savez sans doute
en temps on travaille nous sommes en
phase finale aujourd'hui pour
l'enregistrement d'un vaccin contre le
coc vide qu'on espère enregistrer donc à
l'automne donc une société qui compte
maintenant six cents personnes et qui
est implantée sur différents sites en
europe donc en plus de la france
l'autriche pour la recherche
et puis l'écossé l'as fait pour la
production avec également une
infrastructure commerciale en europe et
aux états unis et au canada et par
ailleurs donc je suis président du pôle
de compétitivité des entreprises du
grand ouest
il faut en remercier alors que cette
mobilisation va bien
[Musique]
moi j'ai pas entendu à bien vos projets
dire quelques mots pour vous présenter
ensuite on commencera les échanges
autour des questions une bécosse que
marc webb
mais je suis à être général d'une start
up qui est issu de la pitié salpêtrière
qui est une qui a une particularité
d'avoir à peu près la moitié des
effectifs de 650 personnes qui sont des
médecins d'infirmières et l'autre moitié
qui les technologies qui développe du
device et deux esquifs ont pas d de rêve
est également l'utilisation donc des
deux sexes dans l'intégration dans des
parcours de soins qui travaille en tant
que privé au service des hôpitaux ca qui
réalisent des actes au service des
hôpitaux dans les lits des autres dans
les lits des hôpitaux ou bien où il ya
un distance autour de l'éco physiologie
donc aujourd'hui on est parisien et des
français avec un assez grosse présence
sur le grand test mais avec des pl est
un plateau de production enfin une ligne
de production et des personnes qui font
tourner les plateaux techniques qui
tourne transnationales et on est
également pour 60% du chiffre d'affaires
aux états unis
je suis par ailleurs dans l'extraction
au mini c'est donc une compétitivité
medicen entre autres ont entre autres
missions sociales et bien écoutez merci
à tous les clubs de cette présentation
c'est la place que les biotech que
prennent dans l'innovation mais aussi
les difficultés qu'ils rencontrent et
c'est l'objet de cette audition alors
moi je vais je posé quelques questions
que vous aurez posé ma collègue annie
del mon corps police qui est rapporteur
rapporteur de cette mission
le premier c'est sur la qualité de
l'examen des demandes d'essais cliniques
on ya beaucoup
beaucoup d'industriels canton et font
face aux aux questions clean aux
questions posées par la haine et c'est
mou par les comités de protection des
personnes sur sur les demandes d'essais
cliniques il formule nous en dit parfois
désarçonné par les questions posées ou
alors par les décisions prises avec
parfois des refus qui ne comprennent pas
qu'il ne comprend pas bien ne pas voir
la question c'est est-ce que vous
partager ce sentiment
j'avais une question pour vale les vapes
si vous avez fait un peu la une de
l'actualité et des collègues avaient
posé question d'actualité à ce sujet le
royaume uni se semble s'être positionné
très tôt comme un partenaire proactif de
votre croissance sur tout sur toute la
chaîne de la recherche finca production
avec un soutien financier significatif
et j'aimerais savoir dans quelle mesure
vos négociations avec les britanniques
ont contrasté avec celle que vous avez
engagé de la commission européenne
l'europe c'est un positionner uniquement
comme acheteuse dans ces négociations et
vous êtes approché en 2020 pour vous
accompagner dans vos développements et
comment se fait-il que le royaume uni
écrit la priorité à l'europe pour
l'accès au vaccin conçu par la biotech
pourtant ce site et lors des auditions
réalisées de l'amant plusieurs
intervenants ont fait état de
difficultés dans l'accès au financement
au delà d'un certain seuil on parle
notamment d'un plafond de verre sur des
investissements de 500 millions d'euros
soit des montants qui par exemple aux
états unis peuvent être obtenus très
rapidement est-ce que les votre
sentiment sur cette notion de de soutien
au financement
est-ce que la durée nécessaire vous
paraît excessive et et quelles seraient
les propositions vous feriez voilà donc
qui commence monsieur grimaud peut-être
vous nous on évacue tout de suite celui
d'hier le sujet ok je vous remercie
non donc sur cette question
effectivement la manière dont l'europe a
approché le sujet covit versus les états
unis ou l'angleterre par exemple je
pense qu'il ya une très très bonne chose
c'est que l'europe a décidé de
centraliser les commandes ça je pense
que c'est un point positif parce que ça
aurait été probablement délétère d'avoir
une compétition son pays européens
donc ça ça s'est mis en place en juillet
2000 femmes simplement effectivement
l'europe n'ayant pas d'outils de
financement de ce type de crises
sanitaires pré établis prémontées s'est
positionné à commencer donc à dialoguer
avec les différentes industriel pendant
l'été et les premiers contrats ont été
signés en septembre octobre novembre
or la course pour développer ces vaccins
avaient étaient à devait nécessairement
commencer les lepic 2020 les états unis
qui ont un outil qui s'appelle le barda
qui doute et plusieurs milliards de
dollars ont qu fait financer à risque si
programme dont celui de cette fille dont
celui de modern à dans celui de novavax
dans celui de strass et des cas par
exemple en mettant pour chaque programme
500 millions d'euros qui est en gros la
somme nécessaire pour aller de la phase
1 à la phase iii et de financer une tout
ou partie de l'industrialisation et donc
les programmes et les vaccins et les
doses que les européens ont acheté en q3
q4 2020 avait en fait été financé à
risque par essentiellement par le bar
d'arles aux etats-unis et pas par
l'europe et nous on s'est retrouvé dans
une situation un petit peu intermédiaire
ou du fait de notre implantation
industrielle en écosse
le royaume uni a considéré que c'était
un positionnement stratégique et qu' ils
étaient ils ont cru aussi très vite dans
notre vaccin inactivé et donc pour
estimer intéressant de pouvoir financer
aussi à risque avec ses publics en
septembre une somme de financement à
risque non remboursable de 470 millions
d'euros sur lequel on a reçu déjà une
somme très très significative + plus de
plus la moitié donc là la leçon que j'en
tire en ce qui me concerne c'est que
un outil équivalent au bar d'à est bon
il ya des réflexions aujourd'hui en
cours pour créer une agence qui
s'appellerait ra her as qu'ils soient
dotés de ces sommes-là enfin il faut
pour qu'elle soit effective qu'elle soit
dotée de 2 10 à 20 milliards d'euros est
pour moi une décision autonome un peu
comme la banque centrale c'est à dire
que je n'ai pas besoin d'attendre l'avis
de chacun des 27 avant de lancer
l'investissement et le pari dans tel ou
tel vaccin
pour que pour lancer la machine
évidemment en contrepartie je demanderai
à avoir des premières doses donc ça
c'est vraiment pour moi la leçon
d'histoire
le point positif centralisation des
commandes mais le point qui manque c'est
d'avoir une agence équivalente au
équivalente au jardin et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui en ce qui nous concerne
nous nous avons donc reçu un financement
qui nous permet aujourd'hui d'être en
phase 3 nous avons reçu un financement
total pour financer une nouvelle une
nouvelle usine et est donc voilà on n'en
serait pas là aujourd'hui sans avoir lu
ce soutien mais c'est la même chose pour
la plupart des vaccins qui sont
aujourd'hui disponibles en europe sans
le barda je pense qu'on n'aurait pas été
aussi vite
donc voila voila je pense que c'est
vraiment la leçon d'histoire c'est qu'il
faut absolument qui est une agence
européenne
qu'ils soient autonomes bien doté et
qu'ils puissent faire agir très
rapidement en cas de crise sanitaire
il faut il faut sera donné pour
l'instant en ce qui concerne la grippe
pandémique quand même qu'on voit
régulièrement
on a eu le soin des vaccins qui était
très pathogène mettrait plus infectieux
soit très infectieux mais plus pathogène
on peut penser qu'un jour on aura envie
les ondes et 2 donc et une prochaine les
crises pandémiques peut arriver et leurs
valets tout à fait les moyens de s'y
préparer c'est juste d'avoir les outils
institutionnels pour pour pour bien il
répondait rapidement il répond j'aurais
un certain nombre de choses à dire aussi
sur le financement les essais cliniques
et tout ça mais je tue m'arrête là pour
l'instant voix sinon vous pouvez
continuer sur les mêmes questions ce
financement et essais cliniques puisque
les questions concernaient vous 4 vous
donnez votre réflexion sur ces deux
sujets et puis ensuite on passera la
parole et on demandera monsieur stéphane
m'bia de karma de se présenter aussi
mais il te dit sur les essais cliniques
et sur les financements voilà alors en
ce qui concerne les essais cliniques
effectivement je pense qu'on a à faire
principalement un problème culturel les
l'innovation biotechnologies
c'est forcément des nouvelles approches
sont forcément d un nouveau type de
médicaments c'est c'est souvent un
minutes à nouveau mode de delivery donc
nounoune par essence la plupart des
innovations biotechnologies sortent des
cases sorte de ce qui est déjà connu et
il est vrai je pense que
c'est souvent ce qui ressort c'est que
entre autres en france mais pas
simplement france on a une approche très
tout de bouc
si on rentre pas dans les cases
si on rentre pas dans les choses qui
sont déjà décrit six voix là on n'est
pas sur des choses connues et bien c'est
et c maximum protection maximale demande
maximum alors que dans un certain nombre
d'autres pays on a une approche beaucoup
plus pragmatique du risque bénéfice quel
est le bénéfice que ce médicament peut
apporter quel est le risque que je
prends en tant qu'agence réglementaire
et est donc ce n'est pas une question
d'infrastructure de pour faire des
essais cliniques
la france est très bien doté il ya un
certain nombre de processus qui doivent
être accélérées etc mais pour moi la
principale
le principal enjeu c'est le le culturel
1 et c'est vrai qu'on l'a vu même pour
le coc vide on a eu des approches plus
ou moins pragmatique en fonction des
pays des agences parce que voilà c'est
quand même une situation très très très
particulière donc ça c'est ce que je
dirai je tirais sur les essais sur les
essais cliniques mais c'est un vrai vrai
gros enjeu parce que derrière évidemment
en termes de soutien et d'une certaine
manière de rapidité d'accès au marché
la phase d'essai clinique était
absolument majeur pour les sociétés de
biotech et le fait de pouvoir arriver au
marché en sur le marché en six ans plus
tôt huit ans est un enjeu économique
énorme l'enjeu de financement énormes et
un enjeu de compétitivité énorme
donc ça c'est vraiment
un point qui fait que beaucoup de
sociétés de biotech française vont faire
d'essais cliniques ailleurs un sas est
la résultante de ça et pour moi c'est
principalement culturel ce qui nous aide
pas beaucoup ce qui fait que c'est un
gros chantier là la deuxième chose que
j'aimerais dire aussi par mon par
rapport aux questions clés que vous avez
posé sur les aspects financement en gros
je trouve qu'en france
là on est bien soutenue pour le
démarrage
on est bien soutenue pour les essais
pour les essais précliniques qui vont
coûter à les réaliser en vous à coup on
a perdu et que d'accord donc ce que je
sais c'est qu'en france on est plutôt
bien soutenue pour les essais cliniques
donc les essais précliniques 1 qui coûte
2 3 4 5 millions pour les essais de
phase 1 qui vont coûter 4 à 5 millions
pour les essais de phase 2 qui vont
coûter 20 millions en gros un là on
trouve des financements on trouve des
capitaux risqueurs la bpi joue un rôle
excellent excellent elle a été
instrumental pour la fusion et la
création d'un débat ils sont aujourd'hui
à hauteur de 10% du capital de vendée va
il joue un rôle extrêmement efficace là
où on a un un blocage pour que les
bibliothèques françaises et européennes
deviennent des pharmas de demain et
arrive sur le marché par elle même on
fait partie des rares sociétés en europe
qui ont un réseau commercial qui
commercialisent leur propre médecin sait
qui et il faut trouver le financement de
la phase 3 qui va coûter en gros 500
millions 600 millions
et là il faut des investisseurs c'est
pas des privés c'est pas des subventions
c'est pas il faut des investisseurs
qu'ils soient capables de mettre 50 à
100 millions d'euros sur une phase 3 qui
est à 50% de risque d'échec il ya encore
un gros risque d'échec en phase iii est
là en europe on a un ou deux fonds qui
sont capables de le faire je dis bien en
europe aux états unis on a 30 à 35 fonds
qui sont capables de le faire et ça ça
c'est un verrou important france biotech
mais ligne depuis 10 ans 15 ans sur le
fait qu'ils aient une partie de par
exemple de l'assurance-vie 2% 3 % 4 %
qu'ils soient alloués et avec des
soutiens fiscaux des incitations
fiscales pour justement me permettent de
monter les gros fonds de doter de
plusieurs milliards qu'ils puissent
faire ce type d'investissement et qui
accompagnent les biotech française
européenne pour ce que c'est cette
dernière phase et ça ça manque ça ça
manque et c'est probablement là à
nouveau il s'agit pas de demander les
subventions à l'état pas de demander des
aides
il s'agit de demander une incitation
fiscale pour que ce type de fonds
puissent se créer et à nouveau ce est à
l'enjeu français mais c'est un enjeu
plus largement européen et puis je une
dernière chose et je terminerai par
rapport à vos questions je pense qu'on a
en europe à nouveau vers suisse les
états unis un prix de un problème de
remboursement des médicaments
aujourd'hui toutes les bibliothèques
vous le diront qu'ils commercialisent 1
qui ont réussi tout les pharmas
d'ailleurs vous le dire en en gros elles
ont 60 % de leur chiffre d'affaires qui
est fait aux états unis et 70 à 75% la
profitabilité qui est fait aux états
unis ça veut dire cette profitabilité
c'est rare et investir en r&d
à que ce soit les pharmas que ce soit la
biotech le profit que l'on fait on leur
ait investi en r&d
on leur ait investi pour développer un
programme des bottes des programmes r&d
1 il faut savoir quand eux commence dit
phase 1 10 phases 1 et avec un seul
médicament qui va arriver jusqu'au bout
il ya 10% de succès quand on commence la
phase 1 c'est le sait le sait les
statistiques pour des milliers de
développement donc il ya un gros risque
qui est pris et le l'europe en général
un de manière assez assez homogène
l'europe en général a choisi de d'avoir
une politique de remboursement jeu que
je vais qualifier de déconner rom et on
va ça s'éteint c'est un sujet puisque
aujourd'hui voilà comme je le disais la
là l'essentiel la profitabilité fait aux
états unis donc à un moment donné ma
télé évidemment les centres de recherche
à on l'aimait proche des clients finaux
important et c est ça je comprends que
ce dernier point est un point
hyper sensible politiquement
d'autant plus que quand on regarde par
exemple l'espérance de vie des européens
versus les américains ont fait mieux
alors que on dépense moins en santé donc
on pourrait dire l'europe
en fait la raison sauf que quand il
s'agit de développer les nouveaux
médicaments est développé et garder une
industrie du futur
on a on a besoin de pouvoir voilà avoir
une une profitabilité sur les
médicaments qu'ils réussissent pour
investir dans lesdits programmes dont un
seul va réussir
voilà donc il ya cette thématique aussi
du prix de remboursement des médicaments
qui est une thématique qui compte aussi
voilà donc je m'arrêterai là ne pourra
pas être trop bon et puis on vous
présentait ensuite mais ces montants
d'accord t'as bien bonjour à toutes et à
tous bon bah un quart matt c'est une
société dont on a même trop parler je
pense en france enfin trop longtemps et
mal d'ailleurs
et donc c'est un sujet très important on
parlait de population vieillissante
comme pour la co vide il ya 40 ans il
aurait pas eu de mort parce que il n'y
avait pas de populations fragiles
on parlait d'espérance de vie on
m'aurait tous à 60 65 ans donc
probablement il ya quarante ans la
commune n'aurait pas frappé comme l a
frappé aujourd'hui parce que les gens
auraient été à l'hôpital avec des
maladies ou complications aux mineurs
dès maintenant les gens vivent jusqu'à
85 ans donc on crée une population
fragile en moyenne c'est encore ça met
un peu plus les femmes un peu moins des
hommes et donc on est en train de créer
une population fragile parce qu'on
traite de mieux en mieux les gens et
donc on vieillit mieux et donc on est en
train de créer de nouvelles pathologies
dont la science cardiaque avancée
donc ça veut dire la défaillance des
deux ventricules de chambre inférieur de
notre coeur c'est une maladie dont on
parlait pas ya 50 ans les listes est pas
et c est l évolution logique d'alain
carpentier donc grand chirurgien
français qui a révolutionné la chirurgie
moderne
on va déjà parlé de siècle dernier ce qu
en 2000 beaucoup tourner la page et à 20
ans donc il ya cinquante ans déjà il
avait pensé il voyait qui est des
nouvelles maladies parce qu'on veut
passer les 60 envoyé cleval vieillissait
et les gens mouraient donc il n'est
comment on va faire pour remplacer les
valves lui-même plaidant qu'il a eu
l'idée de l'utiliser les tissus bovins
donc les animaux il a trouvé un système
pour fixer les tissus les animaux pour
pouvoir les placer dans le corps humain
et remplacer les valves du corps humain
pensez y à 50 ans et puis comme il était
très visionnaire il l'est toujours
d'ailleurs
donc cinq à dix ans après avoir inventé
cette valve qu'il a cédé je pense que
c'est important pour la discussion qu'on
aura après un groupe américain pour que
tu l'as fait la fondation il a créé un
colosse américain grâce à son invention
et un autre français a contribué à faire
exploser ce groupe donc c'est un groupe
hebe duarte qui est née grâce à deux
inventions françaises qui maintenant
évaluer 80 milliards sur la bourse mais
qui sert beaucoup de patients du monde
entier grâce à deux inventions
françaises qui n'ont pas été soutenus et
donc il a inventé cette vanne les dix
ans après il dit mais si on répare les
balmes un jour ou l'autre on va devenir
plus jeu et c'est le muscle du coeur qui
va arrêter de battre caen qui se
projetait déjà en 2000 et quelques il ya
50 ans de ça et c'est là qu'il a demandé
à des gens donc à jean luc lagardère il
a demandé de l'aider parce que les
problèmes qu'on a aujourd'hui mais il
existait il ya 30 40 ans trouver de
l'argent pour une start up avec un
projet à 30 ans très risqué il fallait
très chanceux pour trouver en français
je dirais les poids et donc jean luc
lagardère qui est un entrepreneur
visionnaire lui même il a dit ok je vais
t'aider je donnais une dizaine
d'ingénieurs gratuitement chez matra et
on va commencer
donc c'est l'histoire car matt qu'ahmad
carpentier et matra est donc aujourd'hui
où en est on est bien la société a eu un
agrément pour pouvoir commencer la
commercialisation qu'on espère commencer
en allemagne j'insiste en allemagne pour
parler de remboursement trailer en
france ce mois ci et puis on va
commencer l'étude américaine
on espère dans les semaines qui viennent
également donc voilà c'est carnoët
c est en négociation de prix là non on
négocie jean deux noms pourquoi vous
dites ça va commencer en allemagne bat
parce que en france on a cette
particularité de penser que le patient
français est différent du patient
allemand c'est bien sûr connu au niveau
génétique et biologiques
on est très différents et donc non en
france on redemande des études
françaises pour pouvoir soumettre un
dossier de remboursement alors que dans
tous les pays d'europe
quelle que soit l'origine de patients
c'est suffisant donc on va faire une
étude s'appelle efficace qui a été
financée certes en partie par la chaise
donc on est très reconnaissant
mais bon ça va dit ça veut dire que le
remboursement probablement arrivera en
france peut-être en 2025 2026 je vais
prendre un cas qui est un cas d'école
est un cas unique dans toute l'histoire
du dispositif médical je fais pas de
technologie mais du dispositif banques
les les implants les implants toutes ces
choses là j'ai développé un clip pour la
régurgitation mitrale dans une boîte
américaine mia
il ya dix ans et on a battu le record du
monde parce que vous savez qu aux etats
unis
contrairement aux pharmas les
remboursements sont très lents par
rapport à l'europe mais cette fois ci on
a battu la france a battu les états unis
on a eu deux ans de retard choisir les
états unis avaient huit ans de retard
sur le marquage chez eux mais la france
avait eu 10 ans de retard sur mac donc
les français ont pu bénéficier du clip
qui sauve la vie de milliers de gens
tous les tous les ans et les données
étaient là depuis dix ans - voilà donc
là c'est un peu l'histoire c'est on a d
un système qui est assez rigide
difficile à comprendre je parle de
dispositifs je connais pas la biotech
très bien pourquoi doit-on avoir des
patients français pour avoir
remboursement en france
si quelqu'un peut me démontrer qu'à des
grosses différences anatomiques et
biologique entre nous et nos confrères
transalpins et tout ça je suis preneur
il ya peut-être des données que j'ignore
inferno michel d'une étude
monsieur monsieur long terme par rapport
aux questions sur déjà évoquée mais si
vous voulez compléter par rapport à
roselyne c'est justement et et au
financement mais donc sur les essais
cliniques
je dirais que les choses ont je serai
moins pessimiste que mes petits
camarades parce que je trouve que les
choses évoluent plutôt favorablement
d'abord côté agence du médicament et en
particulier sur les phases précoces et
c'est très important que les phases
précoces se fasse en france parce qu'on
sait très bien que à partir du moment où
on démarre son développement le choix du
pays pour son développement et clé et
donc si on démarre sur les essais
précoces en france on continuera à
développer même si souvent les gros et
c'est deviennent internationaux
ça voudra dire que les patients français
bénéficieront sur les faces tardy aussi
de ses investigations là donc on peut se
réjouir qu allah nsm des choses ont
considérablement progressé à la fois en
termes de délai à la fois en termes
d'instruction donc il y a effectivement
des équivalents temps plein qui ont été
mis à disposition pour ces phases
précoces reste aujourd'hui deux points
je dirais d'amélioration c'est des
comités de protection des personnes
on s'est un peu la tarte à la crème
depuis quelques années maintenant où il
faut effectivement changer cela il y a
eu une réforme qui a conduit au tirage
au sort aléatoire des cpp quand vous
déposez une demande d'essai clinique
vous avez d'un côté à nsn qui jugent de
la recevabilité sur la sécurité du
produit
je fais simple et il est cpp qui se
positionne sur la méthodologie et les
tic est donc là dessus le tirage au sort
conduisait au fait que vous pouviez vous
retrouver avec un ctp
vous développez vous développer un
produit dans la neuro et vous avez alors
cpp qui est plutôt spécialisée dermato
donc vous imaginez les questions que
vous pouvez revoir et d'autre part il y
avait un point et ça c'est toujours un
point aussi un peu de faiblesse suite on
va dire à certains scandales sanitaires
qui est le lien d'intérêt le et le
conflit d'intérêts dans l' expertise où
il ya eu effectivement une grande
crainte que les gens qui ont un qui
travaille pour l'industrie soit des gens
qui sont complique t et qui ne peuvent
répondre souvent l'industrie fait appel
aux gens les plus compétents
donc je ne vous fais pas le raccourci
mais ça veut dire effectivement on sent
qu'on peut se retrouver avec des gens
qui sont pas forcément les plus
compétents dans les domaines qu'on cible
et puis il ya un autre problème c'est
que ce sont les cpp qui doivent
s'estimer être compétent ou non donc
toujours difficile pour un être humain
de s'estimer non compétent dans telle ou
telle de même et donc là les choses on
espère vont évoluer pour pouvoir
effectivement ciblé que tirage au sort
ne soit pas aléatoire ce soit un tirage
au sort qu'ils soient liés aux
compétences des personnes qui sont dans
ccpp
et puis il faut aussi savoir que ccb ce
sont des gens bénévoles qui le font en
plus de leur travail est souvent ce sont
des hospitaliers qui ont une charge de
travail qui est souvent importante donc
là dessus il faut changer cela parce que
ça ça conduit effectivement un frein à
la fois en termes de délais par rapport
à la compétition internationale et qui
fait qu effectivement certains certes
certains quand vous faites des essais
internationaux souvent sur les phases 2
il est vrai que quand on interroge nos
adhérents le lancement du premier
patient français est sans doute le plus
tardif par rapport à d'autres pays y
compris y compris sur les états unis
donc voilà simplement qu'il ya ce point
là est un autre point aussi vous savez
que quand vous contractualiser avec les
centres hospitaliers
vous avez ce qu'on a le ce qu'on appelle
le contrat unique
le contrat unique donc c'est quelque
chose qui aille effectivement
révolutionner cet aspect là pour en
termes juridiques donc un seul contrat
qui est valable pour tout le monde il
reste un point de faiblesse on en a nous
beaucoup parlé avec luc 6 sur la next
financière puisque c'est ça en fait qui
comme toujours constitue une phase de
négociation qui est administrativement
parlant peut prendre des délais qui
seront assez important et quand vous
avez une dizaine de centres en france
qui sont impliqués vous êtes obligé de
faire une négociation avec ses dix
centres et les administratifs pareil
peuvent avoir des difficultés en termes
de bande passante pour instruire c'est
ces demandes administratives de contrat
et donc les deux points de faiblesse
aujourd'hui sont effectivement les
combler comme ici les comités de
protection des personnes et ce contrat
unique il faut peut être revalorisé je
pense que les industriels sont pas
fermées au fait que ce soit revalorisé
si ça permet de gagner du temps ce que
vous savez dans notre industrie le temps
et est un facteur clé en termes de
protection industrielle et c'est donc
tout ce qu'on gagne en terme de temps en
temps au terme de semaines est
considérable par rapport à la
valorisation des entreprises
donc ça c'était pour les essais
cliniques donc sachez qu effectivement
l'on remonte un peu la pente sur les
phases précoces
il reste encore un certain nombre de
domaines où on est vraiment
on est vraiment en retard sur le
financement alors franck l'a dit mais
c'est un peu l'arlésienne la
mobilisation de de l'héparine français
donc je dirais que c'est pas si un jour
on y arrivera mais c'est vrai que ça
reste en tout cas une préoccupation si
on arrive à se dire que c'est une
priorité nationale et qu on arrive aussi
à la culture et les investisseurs sur ce
domaine parce qu'il sait un domaine
particulier c'est un domaine on l'a dit
les les temps sont longs ou un
développement un développement d'un
médicament c'est entre 10 et 12 ans à
partir du moment où il a été identifié
chez sur sa cible et on compte à peu
près entre 1 et 1,5 milliard nécessaires
pour pouvoir le sécuriser en constitue
dans ce 1 5 milliard il est évident
qu'on tient compte aussi de l'attrition
dont franck comprend qu'à part les autos
de deux succès et donc tout ça pour dire
que c'est un domaine qui est très
particulier pour les investissent et nos
sociétés en fait sont bâtis sur en fait
des jalons de création de valeur et pas
des métriques financières classiques
donc pour intéresser les nazis et je
m'explique c'est à dire que ces
investisseurs qui investissent dans la
technologie
ils vont se baser sur des métriques
financières de revenus de chiffre
d'affaires débile da etc
dans le cas des biotech un peu moins
vrai sur les medtechs parce qu'elle peut
générer plus précocément du chiffre
d'affaires est encore moins vrai pour
les soluces les solutions de e-santé
mais pour les biotech en particulier les
investisseurs doivent connaître
justement ces jalons qui sont des jalons
créateur de valeur c'est à dire la
démonstration d'apport chez le patient
la démonstration de sécurité le fait de
rentrer chez l'homme etc
tout ça ce sont des jalons qui dans la
tête des investisseurs qui sont
spécialisés dans le domaine de la santé
sont considérés comme des incréments
dans la valeur de
de l'actif qu'on est en train de
développer et ça c'est pas facile pour
on va dire le l'investisseur
généralistes c'est aussi pour ça que au
delà de la mobilisation de l'épargné
il faut aussi à culture et les
investisseurs à venir sur sur 7 sur
cette industrie là je voudrais
mentionner quelque chose qui me semble
être un énorme levier et qu'il faut
absolument encourager
je pense que vous avez entendu parler du
dispositif déployé par philippe tibi
donc philippe tibi est un prof
d'économie de l'x qui a écrit un essai
sur comment financer la quatrième
révolution industrielle de la france et
en particulier en passant par les
technologies
il avait clairement identifié que on
avait plutôt bien adresser les phases
précoces d'amorçage
on y reviendra sur les fines l'un des
aspects du pays acp et les fonds
d'amorçage ont plutôt été bien doté
alors évidemment c'est jamais suffisant
c'est jamais comparable à d'autres
écosystèmes mais il faut se replacer
aussi dans un contexte français de ce
qu'on est des progrès qu'on a réalisé
sur les dix dernières années en la
matière en revanche qui nous manquait
c'est cesser ces étapes qu'on appelle de
phase tardive de scale up on pas
beaucoup ce terme aujourd'hui en tout
cas on va dire de passage à la phase
industrielle et qui permet d'avancer sur
des phases phase 2b phase iii pré
enregistrement et ça effectivement cédé
montant il faut sécuriser plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros pour
pouvoir pouvoir parvenir à ce stade pas
et philippe tibi donc a mis en place
face à
22 assurantiel et parapublic
un certain nombre de fonds qui opèrent
sur le terrain dans le domaine des
technologies en a 33
sur ces 33 il y en a neuf qui sont dans
le domaine de la santé et ses
investisseurs assurantielle se sont
engagés à mettre plus de 6 milliards
dans le domaine de la technologie
engagés ils ne l'ont pas mis se sont
engagés à le faire et donc c'est les
investisseurs qui opèrent sur le terrain
qui vont venir dans nos sociétés
aujourd'hui certains ont mobilisé 400
450 millions je pense à deux exemples
assez emblématique français vous avez le
fond de giteau qui est dirigé par
raphaël tordjman qui opèrent sur le
terrain justement avec des capacités à
venir sur une cinquantaine de millions
par entreprise et quand vous venez avec
cette capacité là vous attirer aussi
d'autres investisseurs internationaux
donc c'est aussi ça c'est vraiment cette
traction là qu'il faut qu'il faut opérer
il s'avère qu'aujourd'hui par rapport
aux autres domaines technologiques c'est
vrai que les investisseurs généralistes
assurantielle ont plus de mal à venir
sur la santé parce qu'il ya besoin de
cette acculturation il ya besoin de
comprendre quelles sont les métriques a
besoin de les éduquer sur quel est notre
industrie comment elle fonctionne et
comment elles se valorisent et quels
risques ils prennent réellement bon
voila voila un petit peu ce que ce que
je voulais vous dire sur sur le
financement donc un certain nombre de
choses qui progresse incertain de levier
qu'on peut opérer encore et l'ampli est
amplifiée aujourd'hui merci monsieur x
un monsieur frau 1
oui merci donc nous on est dans une
situation un peu différente puisque mon
entreprise n'est pas bio tech
elle est sur le domaine de l'évolution
pathologies chroniques dans pour lequel
effectivement il s'agit de copiloter le
traitement et la prise en charge des
patients en attendant que les biotech
arrive à faire des miracles sur certains
certains certaines solutions sur les
maladies dégénératives donc tout ce qui
est en elle et à l'été en france et
représente quand même de 60 % des coûts
de santé
est ce que nous faisons c'est donc
essayer de
de détendre le médecin donc des de les
aider donc très proche des médecins avec
du médical de rex et ray et avec du
logiciel et avec les organisations un
peu différente en se mettant donc en
sous traitance est en fonctionnement
avec les établissements de santé pour
pouvoir effectivement à mon panier les
patients vers des parcours d'excellence
à chaque fois parcours de santé
l'excellence à chaque fois dans la
complexité elle est différente sur les
techniques c'est pas la structuration
être est ce qu'on est centré coq on
retrouve effectivement avec une biotech
avec pas moins de phase iii et puis même
éventuellement d'aider des phases à
venir derrière une extension de
collection dans d'autres pathologies
ces puces des essais cliniques qui
comptent qui concerne donc les
changements de parcours de soins en
hausse puis en hôpital et il ya autant
de l'innovation je pense à venir ou en
ce secteur qu'il peut y avoir dans
d'autres secteurs de la victime puisque
on peut on peut reprocher l'illusion ou
alice 15 ans on va avoir
systématiquement pour tous les patients
en pathologie chronique un
accompagnement ou les médecins n'étant
plus suffisant en tant que tel et la
complicité de la médecine technique
devant nous non plus lourde
on aura systématiquement un
accompagnement des patients en espèces
de 2 go modèle numérique où je sais pas
exactement comment ça va se traduire
mais qui sera systématiquement à 100%
derrière chaque patient il n'y a pas de
raison qu'on n'ait pas la coordination
de points commencent déjà et aux états
unis là elle représente déjà plusieurs
milliards de chiffre d'affaires
c'était en fait c'est un métier
intermédiaire entre le spécialiste
hospitalière en 3 qui est de 2,2 très
haut niveau
et puis le médecin généraliste qui ne
peut pas être un médecin technique sur
chacun d'eux des pathologistes et
passion et ce domaine là on a un
inconvénient majeur dans le
fonctionnement des essais cliniques et
des fonctionnements c'est que c'est de
l'amélioration continue n'est pas
d'amélioration pour créer un monopole
il s'agit pas de faire ça aujourd'hui
c'est une amélioration sur les parcours
elles sont souvent traduites par des
publications qui n'ont pas de valeur de
valeur en tant que tels ces décès les
publications et après les gars là est né
après les gaines à une sont déployés
dans les hôpitaux ne sont des pays ont
des systèmes 2.1 et là je pense qu'en
france on n'est pas en retard sur ça
beaucoup de médecins qui participent à
ces nouvelles guideline pas rendre la
capture dans un parcours qui serait
digitalisées qui serait piloté comme
longtemps d'industrie 4-0 dans une
médecine de caen 1 0
notre médecine car on peut laver
commenté c'est quelque chose qui est
encore encore l'eau et donc on est dans
des essais cliniques multiples des
petits essais à des essais lourd pas des
essais comme ceux qu'on a décrit tout à
l'heure qui nous demande effectivement
une certaine flexibilité et pour lequel
on travaille nous donc en direct avec
avec les hôpitaux et leur capacité de
faire quelquefois avec des avec un
fonctionnement ce héros qui est un peu
particulier qui ne ressemble pas à celui
qui a passionné que qu'on a
conditionnellement et on travaille aussi
avec des pandas roux ou là par contre il
s'agit d'introduire de nouvelles
molécules juste à temps et au bon moment
et avec avec deco dosage de principe
pour des patients en fin de vie ou des
patients atteints des connexions des pas
de questions très compliquées depuis non
plus compliqué d'ailleurs et il s'agit
de faire du du co-développement et dans
ces cas là quand on part avec les carmes
à ce qu'on observe effectivement c'est
que c'est systématiquement de prendre ça
colle et c'est donc lyon
parme avec lequel on travaille on
systématiquement choisir des soeurs de
prendre et ça et ça je ne sais pas moi
pour autant je suis pas spécialiste de
domaine et je ne sais pas pour autant
répondre pourquoi le pont mais il me
semble que c'est principalement
économiques et le délai sur le temps et
principalement les coûts des essais
cliniques mais le tube pas certain que
toi ça pascal inverse
on a des médecins français qui est
pilote mes médecins français rue du pic
alliés qui sont souvent des professeurs
qui pilote d'essais cliniques qui ont
lieu dans d'autres pays donc c'est bien
des français qui pilote mais il les
réalisations 2016 de francs donc voilà
monsieur les essais cliniques j'ai pas
grand chose à dire moins sûr je sauve sa
terre que on a une partie des évolutions
qui sont préparation des débats faire le
maximum pour les patients est vraiment
être centré son thé public et capacité à
gérer ses parcours qui sont pas le même
type d essais cliniques que ce qui se
fait traditionnellement puisque c'est
une amélioration continue
comment on peut avoir dans le logiciel
en amélioration continue
on a besoin d'amélioration continue
c'est pas les gros delta on va pas
tarder
deux bras systématiquement avec un essai
clinique qui dure un temps assez long
pour un retour on va essayer de trouver
des méthodes différentes pour faire
c'est l'essai clinique en petit
incrément qui correspondent bien des
domaines où il n'y a pas trop de risques
c'est de toute façon une amélioration
aux recherches
par contre on avait nommé avant le
retour on a besoin de pouvoir se servir
des résultats pour les agréments ceo ou
autre et on a besoin d'intégrer tout ça
et dans ces cas là effectivement alors
on a tous ces mots clés un peu un peu
nobles comme l'un des gendres
artificielle et c'est là qu'on
retrouvait autour du des données qui
sont tous là présent et pas loin et ils
servent les essais cliniques qui
correspondent à valider des genres
artificiels par exemple c'est quelque
chose qui aujourd'hui mieux plus avancé
est beaucoup plus avancée unique en
europe mais mais mais pas qu en france
mais même tendance en général parce
qu'elle n'a qu'à envoyer beaucoup de jeu
mais qui vont être des ténors au type
d'essai qui sent qu'ils sont importants
sur le financement je voudrais je
voudrais dire que effectivement financer
une biotech sa demande de biens bien
comprendre des jalons puisque on est
dans un financement on peut pas regarder
les comptes
à l'inversé dans les bottes que le on a
des comptes et on on a le même type de
problème par contre je pense que pour un
entrepreneur c'est un privilège de faire
de l'argent gestionnaire normalement
perdent pas d'argent à un entrepreneur
perdre de l'argent parce que il est en
investissements et créer de la valeur
aux actionnaires ils essayent de créer
un maximum de valeur actionnaire le plus
vite qui peut et donc il le crée avec
avec des contraintes qui sont de faire
fonctionner son entreprise
et là on est dans un domaine un peu
différent puisqu'on et on doit se
rapprocher plus de ce qui s'est fait
dans le numérique avec de plus en plus
souvent des modèles ou où les âmes aide
aux parents avec des financiers
américains
on est capable de perdre de l'argent
pendant beaucoup plus longtemps que
quand on est capable de le faire en
france et sur des sommes beaucoup plus
importantes
alors on va se rapprocher les modèles
qui sont plus de amazon hubert et ses
années mais d'une façon générale perd de
l'argent depuis longtemps demande de
levée plus d'argent donc demande d'avoir
des financements plus importants et
demande de passer à l'échelle supérieure
alors moi mon entreprise on est on est
on en a parlé hier on n'a pas besoin de
lever autant d'argent n'a pas besoin
d'essais cliniques de 500 millions par
contre on parle quand même en centaines
de millions et effectivement si on veut
des centaines de millions avec des
investisseurs
en france qui sont capables donc d'être
les lignes leicester se déclenche ce qui
a été expliqué tout tout de suite qui
déclenche l'investissement des autres
derrière
et forcément sur le territoire il faut
avoir en tout cas au moins l'un des
mines bester parce qu'un américain qu'il
a investi reçurent un moine européen qui
restait sur la france 2 qui est
quelqu'un qui soit très proche de la
réglementation française et des
relations de travail dans le territoire
pour que ça puisse se faire
c'était très difficile bon honnêtement
je trouve que ça c'est de plus en plus
facile donc la france a fait un énorme
travail et pays et chez nous aussi au
capital et des pays internet on
travaille sur ces phases préalables pour
le scale up les besoins donc j'ai besoin
que tu abandonnes centre en centaines de
millions une partie donc effectivement à
venir
une partie je pense tu peux venir pour
nous à l'inversé des biotech des clients
sert de nativité qui sont rentables avec
une première ligne de produit une
deuxième ligne de solutions aux
problèmes de fonction qui vont
contribuer à ces terres et des exposants
de financement qui reste très important
car l'entreprise ne sont pas
immédiatement rentable mais mais capable
de contribuer et sur cette partie là je
pense que là les mots mission à
l'excellent qu'on a discuté tout à
l'heure sur les vaccins car quand c'est
un cofinancement de enfin également dans
les situations idéales
il faut que ce soit un conte financement
puisque ce sont des choses qui ont aidé
les cours de mise en marché sur lequel
talent d'un côté et sur la commande
publique de l'autre ou en tout cas
l'autorisation de travailler en médecine
ou l'autorisation de travailler pour que
les pour que la commande publique puisse
arriver est là dessus c'est vrai que en
un peu de mal en france d'aujourd'hui
par exemple pour les membres
d'entreprises que les leurs complètement
nous travaillons en grande sous
traitance d'une centaine
d'établissements de santé
donc tous les actes que mon jeu dans
tout le travail que nous faisons et et
et koné dans le système hospitalier donc
dans les ghs hospitalier ou dans une
banque ou dans la facturation à l'acte
et pour que ça puisse passer
territoriale et qu'on puisse travailler
sur toute une région
on aurait besoin de portail et gameiro
finesse salir être capable
directement prendre le numéro tkd
sociale des patients est facturé la cpm
et ça aujourd'hui en france par exemple
il ya un blocage de principe du
ministère de la santé sur le fait que
puisse y avoir des entreprises privées
qui travaillent sans contrainte
géographique sur tout le territoire
je pense que c'est justifié j'ai pas de
débat là dessus par le fait que pour
contrôler nos dépenses de santé on
contrôler l'offre et on ne rompt
s'assure que y ait pas de crèches 1 au
maximum et en contrôlent pas que le que
que on contrôle vont contrôler les
dépenses par l'offre autant contre les
dépenses par le prix donc ça c'est s'est
justifié mais ça n'empêche pas que ces
blocs en est que les champions mondiaux
du domaine dans lequel je suis qui
auront donc là des solutions complètes
de suivi de pathologies chroniques et
qui vont représenter un peu plus les
modèles du numérique un plus des modèles
de dégâts femmes dans dans le futur ce
seront les personnes qui ont un
territoire local qui permet d'adopter
donc nous nous faisons 60% match il faut
le marché américain le marché américain
paye mieux que le marché français c'est
sûr il est aussi plus compte
il est aussi plus concurrentiel dans
notre domaine il est beaucoup plus
concurrentiel
on n'a pas un monopole comme encore un
monopole une fois qu'on a qu'on a réussi
à faire un développement de médicaments
donc on a effectivement beaucoup de
concurrence et dont le système américain
il ya une complexité de mise en marché
qui sont qui sont là coûte plus cher
aussi et je crois que le marché matériel
meteab les plus simples mais il est bien
plus facile en retenue il est aussi
beaucoup plus complet puisqu'il ya ne
nous nous avons des contrats avec avec
presque 500 payeur 500 donc payant
américain et différentes formes taillées
taille c'est parce que certains sont
répartis par étapes programmées
bon il à couvrir les les 200 250 mandat
américain pour le cadre des contrôles
des capacités de cette heure donc sur
les essais cliniques mon mais mon
message à moi c'est il ya un nouveau
type d'essai clinique doit pouvoir se
faire qui sont des ces cliniques en un
crémant qui correspondent plus aux
modèles numériques et pas des cqp aussi
structuré que ce qu'on avait et
effectivement à faire en un crémant et
en continu
et en modifications continuelles et ça
le système n'est vraiment pas prêt à ça
et puis le deuxième deuxième élément
c'est une financement et commande
publique
en tout cas capacité de nury sur le
territoire sont directement liés pour
moi et pour nous en tout cas et qu'on
voit c'est que là tu l'as tuée pour
passer dans des phases qu'elle présente
entente diablement ya besoin quand même
de travailler un peu de réfléchir un peu
puis dansé et consommé avoir envie quand
on finance de consommer sur le
territoire ce qui est développée sur le
territoire
et ça c'est ce qui s'est fait avec le
vaccin je pense que le modèle à devrait
être une entretien
et si on veut déployer des entreprises
avec du succès que ce soit dans le
domaine dans le domaine format ou dans
le domaine biotech ou dans le domaine
e-santé au logiciel qui accompagnent
d'une façon générale il faut que les
deux les deux merci je vais passer la
parole à véronique guillotin qui va
poser en effet la question puisque elle
rapporte cette cette mission et ensuite
vous pourrez y répondre et rajouter 3
par rapport aux questions prenez
véronique oui merci présidente
j'ai des questions mais beaucoup de
réponses quand même aux étés ont été
donnés dans les exposés ça va peut-être
permettre de recentrer haut de deux
mètres des focus sur certains sur
certains points la première en fait
c'était je voudrais revenir sur les
essais de phase et 2 dont on sait où en
fait dont on dit qu'en france ils sont
peu importants la france reste au 5e
rang européen avec 6 mai chiffres sont
bons 5% seulement de ces essais qui sont
tous les essais de phase 1 et 2 est ce
que vous observez la même tendance dans
des aires thérapeutiques par exemple
comme les vaccins et ont entendu parlé
tout à l'heure de la cardiologie est ce
qu'il ya une explication on a parlé de
d'explication culturel mais est-ce qu'il
ya d'autres explications donc en tout
cas avez vous un éclairage abonnés sur
sur cette situation et peut
éventuellement évoqué la frilosité des
autorités chargées de l'examen des
dc pour des phases qui présente en fait
des risques pour la sécurité est par
définition les risques sont plus élevés
peut-être sur des phases 1 et 2 dont ça
a été évoqué mais si c'est impossible de
repréciser et on sait que l' approche
est différente dans certains pays on
évoque souvent l'allemagne la belgique
ou l'espagne
sk effectivement vous avez donc sur ce
sujet là un avis particulier et puis une
deuxième question en fait sur la
valorisation des résultats de la
recherche publique et joue en tant que
quelques industriels avez vous été amené
à négocier avec des structures publiques
de recherche pour acquérir des brevets
avez vous rencontré des difficultés dans
la cession de cette propriété
intellectuelle notamment avec l'esat et
enfin dernière dernière question j'ai
juste une question sur la course au
développement des vaccins et le registre
national de candidats aux essais
cliniques qui a élaboré le royaume uni
pensez-vous d'une façon générale que cet
outil peut être un outil qui peut être
considérée comme un facteur
d'attractivité pour les pays et
notamment pour un pays comme la france
ait un qui commence
monsieur pierre à l'aîné puisque non
mais y'a pas de problème peut-être que
je reviendrai sur puisqu'on parle
toujours de j'aime bien ces tables
rondes mais en même temps c'est un peu
frustrant parce que on parle de cas et
d'histoire je pense que c'est bien les
tactiques et décrire les situations mais
c est mieux de comprendre
l'environnement parce que ces
discussions les a depuis longtemps et je
pense que le temps presse
je dirais il dans une minute pour quoi
en tout cas ce que je pense
alors pour revenir à vos questions plus
précisément bombe à la première question
je suis d'accord avec franck
alors je sais pas si c'est lié au
nouveau directeur de la ms m
probablement mais j'ai vu une attitude
totalement du différentes et donc que je
tiens à souligner parce que j'ai
vraiment un état d'esprit qui a vraiment
changé depuis l'an dernier
directrice
d'ailleurs j'ai vu de parler à la
télévision alors extrêmement brillante
et c'est le jour et la nuit donc je
tenais à le souligner
comme quoi oui comme quoi le mal fait
dans le passé a été réparé et je pense
c'est de bon augure pour la santé en
général en france alors au deuxième
point votre poste votre votre question
oui en effet le problème c'est que
l'innovation c'est la certitude et
j'avais adressé une lettre à mon arrivée
il ya cinq ans en france chez quart matt
une lettre ouverte à l'ex directeur de
l'année celle où j'avais expliqué ce
qu'était une innovation ce qui est
dommage parce que c'est ce qui doit
fêter tous les jours je vais expliquer
l'innovation c'est une incertitude c'est
pas plus compliqué que ça c'est comme le
disait un des exposants
quand vous innovez vous découvrez ça
c'est normal
alors c'est clair que si vous aimez pas
l'incertitude vaut mieux changer de
métier parce que l'innovation c'est ça
la recherche
on a un objectif on a un dessin on a un
plan mais on sait pas ce qu'on veut
ouais et bien sûr il peut y avoir des
problèmes
on l'a vu avec les vaccins les
complications ce qui a ému les gens mais
bon peut-être que les gens sont pas
incompétents pour parler des études
cliniques des vaccins mais bon et donc
c'est normal et donc face à
l'incertitude ya du réaction parce qu'on
a peur ou soit en regardant on raisonne
et on dit voilà on va repartir peut-être
différemment et mon expérience ça fait
trente ans que je travaille dans le
dispositif médical
quand je travaillais en majorité ce
toujours débout amérique a
malheureusement fait bondir les bras
pourquoi ce sont des groupes américains
pour que les groupes français mais je
n'ai jamais fait l'étude en france et
c'était mon choix parce que c'est très
lent pouces était très lent pour les
approbations et une fois que vous étiez
parti vous étiez bloquer tout le temps
et je vous donnais un cas très récents
comme ça en moins donc le premier est là
c'est que vous parlez frilosité en effet
c'est un problème de chevet de visiteurs
pourquoi la frilosité
c'est ça la question parce que pourquoi
dans les autres pays les gens sont pas
frileux alors je pense qu'il ya un
problème franck le souligner je pense
que honnêtement il ya eu manque de
personnes au niveau quantitatif donc
déjà ils peuvent pas traiter tous les
dossiers en temps et en heure c'est le
premier point et nous le disent ils sont
frustrés il ya un problème et
qualitatifs donc un problème de
compétences et pas parce que les gens
comprend sont pas compétents mais quand
on regarde le dispositif médical
le directeur disposition médical
s'occupe des crèmes cosmétiques jusqu'au
coeur artificiel
donc même si la personne est brillante
c'est très difficile de comprendre ce
que fait une seringue un pace-maker et
un défibrillateur une prothèse de hanche
une prothèse de genou au mois mon
premier rapport avec la nsn quand je
suis venu en france ya cinq ans la
directrice du médical disposition medica
qui était très très sûr partie ça je
dois dire elle mais elle s'est présentée
elle me dit voilà je m'occupe des crèmes
jusqu'au coeur artificiel et là j'ai
compris le problème donc clairement
c'est très difficile pour eux d'être
préparée donc ça c'est le problème
donc quand on sait pas après soit on
fait confiance et diront on laisse aller
mais quand c'est des sujets aussi
clivant qu'un sujet comme quart matt qui
a été on va sur médiatisé et en plus
quand nos produits notre produit
s'arrête c'est la mort c'est pas c'est
pas un stand qui s'occupent à ce moment
là une autre artère qui peut compenser
nous le produit s'arrête c'est la mort
donc bien souvent les gens veulent pas
exposer ils ont peur des médias et
cetera et cetera
donc qu'est ce que j'ai fait il ya cinq
ans je suis parti de la france
et là notre monde a changé on a
travaillé avec des centres qui était
équipé qui est qu'ils connaissaient
l'innovation parce que le mal de ne pas
faire d'innovation et de typique en
france c'est mal pour le médecin puisque
le médecin il va pas être vraiment au
fait des nouvelles technologies il va
pas pouvoir se développer
il va pas vouloir participer au congrès
aux discussions mondiales
c'est ça le vrai problème parce qu'à la
fin de patients il aurait le produit
parce que l'étude on va la faire
ailleurs et l'agrément il viendra de
toute façon mais si les médecins qui
perdent c'est la médecine qui perd parce
qu'elle ne participe plus à l'innovation
donc ça c'est le premier problème donc
moi il ya cinq ans j'ai fait le choix de
partir ça s'est très bien passé on a
fini notre étude et puis un moment donné
bon la france est bon on est français
déjà des investisseurs en plus ils y
tiennent donc on a il faut qu'on
revienne en france donc on a fait le
choix de revenir en france
la coville a été un facteur important
puisque c'est vrai qu'il est difficile
de faire des opérations à distance avec
la cobi les transporte donc on est
revenu en france on a fait deux patients
je passe vu la chance de word
le film sur la bbc et le patient de
trente ans qu'on a sauvés mais c'est
assez éloquent eh bien on a eu des feeds
à la met des heures vraiment anodine
eh bien on a eu lors la déco les
réunions mais pourquoi mais comment et
comment ça se fait alors que les autres
pays ils ont dit c'est normal c'est la
vise et ici je me suis dit ça y est
c'est reparti bon ça c'est bien parce
que les deux patients ça s'est très bien
terminée dont tout le monde est content
mais ça a été encore il était en crise
quand on a repris l'étude en france six
étaient comme çà ou là ou là là et dès
qu'on a eu une alarme or la cgt
mais bon ça s'est bien passé donc trop
frileux je pense qu'ils manquent de
personnes pour le dispositif et il
manque de compétence dans les gens les
élus ils sont ils font leur mieux non il
faut pas les fustiger mais je pense que
c'est pas structuré pour soutenir les
études cliniques en france
le deuxième point je parlerai pas de
vaccin bien sûr le deuxième point c'est
les structures publiques
alors bien sûr les pays acp c'est le
problème du pays a de toute façon c'est
que on veut un peu copié leur parle tour
d'amérique c'est le moi j'interviens des
habitants d'amérique dont il faut pas
non plus rêver hein c'est pas non plus
il dorado mais bon je pense qu'on peut
pas comparer la france et l'amérique
aujourd'hui parce que on a honte on
compare des poires et des pommes
alors pourquoi la structure publique
n'ont trahi les laboratoires
quand on est obligé je dis bien quand on
est obligé pourquoi quand on est obligé
seulement parce que le laboratoire
américain
c'est pas le laboratoire français et
c'est très différent nous contraignent
les laboratoires français c'est parce
qu'on est contraint parce qu'en terme de
dynamique en termes d'urgence en termes
de structure en termes de ressources
mais ils sont à la rue donc nous
travaillons laboratoires publics c'est
perdre du temps c'est perdre du temps
nous on fait des choses on travaille
beaucoup très vite hélas le rythme et
les différents il manque de moyens on
parle de laboratoire je vais prendre un
cas français donc quand je travaillais
un san francisco donc on se rencontrer
entre français il y avait un
polytechnicien très brillant et
les partis parce qu'il était dans un
laboratoire je vais pas le nommer un
institut très connu en france était
frustré parce que quand ils voulaient
faire un truc le maximum qu'ils
pouvaient avoir 6 500 mille euros pour
un projet de deux ans non qui va ou dans
un laboratoire public
alors là il a découvert un autre monde
on peut librement institute 1 au nord de
san francisco
et là il va avoir 100 chefs et voilà
j'ai un projet lui faut combien 5
millions et lui dit vous blaguez
j'espère une fourre moins 20 millions si
vous voulez porter le et il est parti à
25 millions donc c'est ça la grosse
différence c'est que je pense qu'il ya
déjà un problème budgétaire qui est
flagrant on le sait et puis comme il
n'ya pas de budget dont bien sûr vous
des cours allégé les gens de joindre ses
structures les gens qui ont envie de
faire de la recherche fondamentale et
les rites us en différents et nous
contrats avec les laboratoires c'est oui
ces gens chez de rtt de trucs
et comme on disait dans les start up on
a dû me on a du mal à avoir de l'argent
on a du mal à l'argent et le temps c'est
de l'argent et on peut pas avoir un truc
à six mois si on perd un truc à un mois
ailleurs dont le prend et c'est ce qu'on
fait et je pense que le problème il est
là
- l'an dernier en plus avec l'aco vie
tous les laboratoires étaient fermés
tous
on a failli manquer quelque chose de
très important parce que ben
malheureusement on a fait avec un
laboratoire aux us parce qu'ils étaient
tous fermés donc il ya un problème de
deux d'état d'esprit
donc je pense qu'on peut pas comparer
les deux systèmes j'ai vu je sais pas si
vous l'avez écrit vous comparer mais et
mighty lit vraiment institute c'est je
pense que si on veut vraiment qui et
c'est avec des pays acp qu'on va pouvoir
aider l'industrie à ceux à travailler
que le public sait qu'il faut structurer
le public et quand vous aurez quelque
chose attractif pour le privé je vous
jure que le privé m'a sauté sur le
public n'y a pas de problème mais il
faut rendre le public attractif et une
valeur de propositions autrement voilà
je vais peut-être déjà revenir sur la
question la question des agences dans la
préparation du rrq 6 et évoqué la
création d'une agence de l'innovation en
santé il a été évoqué tout à l'heure par
monsieur primo je crois grimaud pardon
l'importance du rôle qu'avait joué
labarda dans le cas de la pandémie
l'intérêt qu'il y aurait à créer la
future agence européenne les rats à
condition évidemment qu'elle soit dotée
de moyens et donc en clair qu'on est une
agence européenne bien dotées capable de
réagir rapidement
est-ce que la création d'une agence
d'une migration en santé dans notre pays
serait pertinent quel pour la tête selon
vous les contours de cette agence et
quel pourrait être son positionnement
pour accompagner le développement
qu'unique industrielle d'aidés biotech
et comment cette agence pourrait
interagir avec la future agence
européenne même si on n'est peut-être
pas sûr mais même sujet puisque la lune
serait dédiée à l'anticipation de crise
sanitaire alors que l'otan serait sur
l'innovation mais regard de vos propos
notamment autour de la rsm et j'ai bien
à noter que l'asm était en progrès mais
d'un autre côté il y avait quand même
des points à améliorer
un manque de ressources humaines un
problème qualitatif un manque de moyens
est-ce qu'il est pertinente créer une
agence en innovation ou est ce qu'il
faudrait pas renforcé la haine smg pas
forcément la réponse mais j'aimerais
avoir avoir votre éclairage et s'il y
avait une agence en innovation en santé
qui a été créé de quels moyens
devrait-elle disposez alors c'était
difficile à évaluer mais enfin vous avez
qu à une parfaite connaissance du
domaine
donc j'aimerais avoir votre éclairage et
puis un sujet qu'on n'a pas abordé on te
croit pas beaucoup on a beaucoup
beaucoup insisté sur la difficulté
d'avoir des procédures accélérées dans
notre pays pour permettre l'accès
précoce les patients à des à des
thérapies innovantes dont je reviendrai
pas dessus
par contre une question sur sur la
procédure de marquage ce est ce qu'elle
est aussi efficiente et protectrice sur
le plan de sécurité que les procédures
d'autorisation des dispositifs médicaux
aux états unis et est ce qu'il faudrait
faire évoluer la procédure spécifique
aux dispositifs médicaux en europe pour
garantir un accès aussi précoce que
possible au dispositif innovant mais on
en revient peut-être tout simplement sur
le même sujet de la frilosité des moyens
et de la question des études sur des
patients français pour obtenir un
remboursement voilà je vous remercie
gilles micro lors
il faut allumer ton micro brigitte voilà
oui oui merci merci madame la présidente
moi j'ai deux questions la france s'est
engagée dans la création de la mise en
place de la plateforme de données de
santé ouest data pub afin d'améliorer le
pilotage des ressources de 2 en données
dans le champ de la santé
ce gip dont fait l'objet d'un
financement public qui est conséquent et
intègre un grand nombre de data
scientiste pouvez vous nous faire part
de vos premières évaluations de
résultats de cet investissement qui
utilisent des traitements
d'algorithmique de l'intelligence
artificielle dans le domaine de la santé
et quel est l'impact de la plateforme de
données de santé sur vos entreprises
et quel était le favori the tail
la recherche et puis j'ai une deuxième
question hier sur une radio nationale le
sujet de la greffe du coeur a été a été
prêté lors de l'émission une une machine
innovante a été présentée permettant de
conserver un greffon cardiaque quelques
heures supplémentaires donc de prévoir
un temps de transport plus long de
quatre heures dans une glacière
traditionnels grâce à cette machine
il est alors possible de préserver un
coeur jusqu'à de 2 6 à 8 heures elle est
conçue notamment de façon à pouvoir
transfuser le coeur avec le son pendant
le trajet elle te vous aussi
enthousiaste que le journaliste sur
l'organe care system qui après il se
présente comme l'avenir de la
transplantation cardiaque
merci très bien madame jacques points
oui merci merci madame la présidente
bonjour à toutes et à tous oui je
faisais écouter messieurs avec attention
on savait que la recherche en france
avec quelques difficultés mais là on
nous avait vraiment donner des exemples
bien précis qui nous laisse comme ma
collègue songeur j'aurai deux questions
en fait apposer une peut-être plus
spécifiquement à monsieur franck grimaud
vous avez parlé d'un vaccin futures sur
la maladie de lyme
alors je voulais si vous pouvez nous
donner quelques précisions sur les
délais
quand est ce que vous pensez qui pourra
être mis sur le marché et ma deuxième
question concerne le diagnostic de la
maladie de lyme
je sais qu'en médecine humaine il ya des
grosses difficultés pour poser ce
diagnostic et je vous ferai pas de mon
expérience de le vétérinaire j'ai été
surprise à plusieurs reprises de voir
arriver dans ma clinique des patients
donc ça veut dire des humains qui venait
me demander la possibilité de faire
analyser leur sang dans nos laboratoires
d'analysés vétérinaire qui sont tout à
fait en mesure de diagnostiquer avec
précision et avec sûreté cette maladie
là donc on est il du test et des
diagnostics en france est-ce que dix
évoluent et pourquoi un tel blocage est
ma deuxième question c'est concernant
justement l'attractivité de la france en
matière de recherche clinique et
production bio pharmaceutique qui à
notre sens doit devenir une priorité
économique d'autant plus après la crise
sanitaire ce que nous avons connu alors
en dehors d'améliorer l'attractivité des
carrières des chercheurs en france et
vous nous l'avez démontré pour éviter la
fuite d'un autre pays
il ya bien sûr des financements
entrevoit à prévoir mais est ce que
l'environnement réglementaire doit être
adaptée et quelle serait pour vous les
priorités en termes d'innovation en
santé voilà je vous remercie
laurence rennes caen terminée
oui merci madame la présidente persie
messieurs pour l'apport que vous nous
avez donné ce matin
donc vous avez souligné effectivement
que en tout cas c'est ce que j'ai j'ai
interprété que les données concernant la
france dans le domaine de la recherche
et du développement
finalement indique que nombre de décès
clinique ne se font pas dans l'hexagone
en tout cas que ils ont énormément
diminué ces dernières années
ne pensez-vous pas en fait que cette
baisse
outre ce que vous avez dit sur les
tracasseries et c est ce que vous ne
pensez pas quand même que cette baisse
est le résultat de la diminution des
centres justement de recherche et le
développement si je pense à sanofi par
exemple est très implanté dans ma ville
eh bien on passe en quelques années de
11 centres à seulement 3 diato donc
évidemment ces problématiques donc
comment est ce que vous vous pensez
ou en tout cas inverser les choix qui
sont faits et dont les conséquences sont
négatifs pour tout le monde ça c'est ma
première question j'avais une seconde
question effectivement sur les agences
mais ma collègue corinne imbert les a
posées effectivement je pense que il ya
le besoin on le voit par exemple pour
une agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament
le gouvernement donne de plus en plus de
missions à cette agence avec de moins en
moins de moyens donc évidemment il n'ya
pas quand même en tout cas les camps je
sais j'exagère un peu en faisant moins
en moins de moyens en tout cas pas les
moyens qui seraient nécessaires pour les
missions qui leur sont données donc mon
corps et ma mère a posé la question m'a
donc ma deuxième question en fait c'est
je voudrais je voudrais avoir des
éléments plus précis parce que il me
semble que finalement vous toucher vous
le cir et je voudrais savoir finalement
laquelle l'apport par rapport à ce que à
votre domaine
de recherche et puis finalement quelles
obligations qu'elles devoir vous avez en
retour je vous remercie
très bien on va commencer monsieur
grimaud ou pouvait lire une question
concernant la main là des lames et puis
si vous souhaitez aussi complété par
rapport aux autres questions
ouais je vais essayer d'aller très vite
parce que on a aussi nos contraintes de
temps la lime on espère faire lancer un
essai clinique de phase 3 l'année
prochaine
et puis résultats 2024 lancement 2025
en ce qui concerne les allèles et les
questions diagnostic je pense que c'est
aussi bon il ya eu beaucoup
d'améliorations de fait mais c'est aussi
encore un peu mais de moins en moins une
méconnaissance de la part des médecins
de cette de cette maladie et un certain
nombre de ces symptômes sont considérés
comme non non liés au live donc et les
gens sont poussés au diagnostic sur la
question de l' agence pour l'innovation
à la santé en ce qui me concerne
peut-être mais connexes ont un avis
différent mais je pense qu'on meurt en
france de créer un organisme après un
autre organisme après un autre organisme
on a beaucoup beaucoup trop de couches
beaucoup trop organise donc tous les
sens qui coûte cher à gérer je pense
qu'on aura la bpi qui fonctionne très
bien certains d'organisation de
recherche comme l'inserm de ton les
mieux mais ne créeront pas encore d'une
agence supplémentaire en ce qui concerne
la préparation à des pandémies ou à des
crises sanitaires s'étale au niveau de
l'europe que ça joue et donc il faut il
faut monter cette barre des européens il
faut le 2 t il faut lui donner pouvoir
un pouvoir autonomie mais une agence de
plus voilà je pense que c'est un des
problèmes français c'est qu'on crée une
agence par problème on se fait en ce qui
concerne il a été évoqué juste avant la
question de jeu
native de vaccination je prends je
confirme qu'effectivement pour en
l'occurrence pour lui ce qu'on a on a
fait nos essais cliniques initiaux en
angleterre maintenant on va faire
d'essais cliniques ailleurs y compris il
y compris en europe là la création de
ces registres nationaux ont permis de
faire des essais cliniques très très
très rapidement de ce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de beaucoup de volontaires bon
maintenant je pense que c'est les mais
c'est peut-être une idée à reprend pour
pour l'avenir en ce qui concerne donc
l'intervention aussi baisse des centres
de recherche de sanofi en france je
pense que c'est un révélateur de ce qu
on l'a dit précédemment 1 sur le fait
que je suis jeune je n'ai pas les
chiffres en taille mais je suppose que
pour sanofi la la
le chiffre d'affaires en france doit
représenter peut-être moins de 3 à 4 5%
de son chiffre d'affaires qui met aussi
les centres de recherche là ou là où
sont ses clients il faut les comprendre
il faut il faut comprendre les
pathologies des patients
donc c'est aussi révélateur de tout ça
ayant dit cela et c'est là qu'il ya la
biotech est utile
depuis maintenant 15 ans 20 ans un
médicament sur deux qui est mis sur le
marché vient des biotechnologies vient
des sociétés de technologie
le vaccin qu'ovide a été très révélateur
cette relaxe 1 sur 10 viennent des
biotechnologies y compris pour les
vaccins kaiser a mis en place ou
qu'astrazeneca mis en place ça vient des
biotechnologies donc c'est pour ça que
le enfonçons des parades de thé je
reviens à nouveau c'est le financement
il faut aider c'est le financement privé
cdc des fonds privés qui puisse
permettre de faire cette phase iii est
d'emmener de permettre à la société de
biotechnologie commercial
et c'est ça qu'il faut sur lesquels il
faut avancer et dernier point peut-être
sur le web data je pense que c'est une
excellente idée ça fait partie les
délais des choses d'avenir mais là
encore il va falloir qu'on fasse
attention on dit 1 il ya un adage de
plus en plus fin qui est intéressant les
sièges une innove la chine copie et là
l'europe réglemente il va falloir sur
cette histoire de web data heures que
l'on fasse attention tout en respectant
les données des patients en anonymisant
évidemment un sas et la base des groupes
permettent de l'utilisation de ces
données pour les sociétés de biotech les
sociétés de pharma pour accélérer encore
les et cliniques et accélérer les
corrélations entre est et tel ou telle
maladie
si on peut on le fait que réglementer à
nouveau on va prendre un wagon de retard
donc cette initiative est bonne mais il
va falloir laisser les sociétés privées
y accéder et les utiliser dans des
bonnes conditions éthiques évidemment
voilà je souhaiterais pour ce qui
concerne positif médicale oui alors
rapidement
je pense que alors c'est un problème
d'économie de son ce que l'on parle
d'études cliniques c'est sa voix de
l'économie il faut qu'on crée un
écosystème
je pense a fait 40 ans qu'on voit notre
filière qui est en train de disparaître
en pharma et en l'âge allait
jamais n'est en fin de compte
et comme on est en train d'assister à
une concentration des deux secteurs
si on attend encore dix ans il y aura
même plus on parlera même plus de start
up
alors ça c'est le premier point donc je
pense que c'est discussion utile mais il
ya vraiment besoin d'un vrai plan ont
parlé de plan marshall quand j'étais à
l'elysée de ça mais bon si on veut une
fille de santé en france
mais pour moi c'est un problème
industriel d'emploi c'est pas faire de
la recherche pour la fierté d'avoir
développé un vaccin
premier point second point et je pense
qu'aucun arabe de se complaire dans
cette situation parce que qu'est-ce que
l'innovation l'innovation s'est créé des
start up ou le critère de succès c'est
avoir un médicament qui marche
je suis content de savoir qu'on a 60
nouvelle boîte tous les ans mais si on à
0 et 6 1
partie de la réponse pour laquelle on
n'a pas de financement ce qu'on appelle
en anglais le track-record il est
quasiment zéro il n'y a aucune société
qui est sorti vers le haut depuis dix
ans en france dont aucun à leicester
américains ou étrangers même français il
dit voilà montré moins quatre succès qui
fait que je vais penser qu'en france on
à l'écosystème pour réussir en biotech
et en ya pas il n'y a pas un cas
probants et ça c'est la grosse
difficulté donc faut qu'on crée un
écosystème donc l'innovation c'est ça et
il faut qu'on arrête j'ai publié il ya
des années un papier avec le président a
cité européenne de cardiologie sur
l'innovation et l'innovation c'est un
triumvirat
si l'industrie c'est les médecins
essaient les gouvernements les payeurs
les régulateurs ce que vous voulez et
ils doivent travailler ensemble et
l'industrie faut arrêter de penser que
l'industrie c'est le grand satan
oui c'est une industrie il faut des
capitaux si on n'accepte pas vous avez
vu les vaccins on développera pas c'est
un fait on n'aime pas mais c'est le
monde dans lequel on vit aujourd'hui il
changera peut-être les médecins faut
arrêter de penser et ça c'est le
problème de l'année sème également
peut-être dans le passé c'est le seul
pays on n'a pas le droit de prendre des
gens qui ont des contrats avec des
industries on pense au conflit si vous
avez un conflit saviez vous avez un
intérêt pour quelque chose
ce n'est pas de conflit d'intérêts si
vous n'êtes pas intéressant de se poser
la bonne question est donc on est le
seul pays où on peut pas prendre des
gens compétents parce que
malheureusement comme ils sont
compétents sont ils à l'industrie et la
troisième partie c'est que le lan et
sème donc je suis content recréer des
silos je suis d'accord il faut les
renforcer
il faut leur donner les moyens parce
qu'ils peuvent les bisons la bonne
volonté c'est pas leur problème montlaur
d'un plein de mission ils sont saouls
stafler et il faut pas séparer encore
l'innovation c'est un état d'esprit
c'est une stratégie
c'est une vision et il faut qu'il parle
+11 de ce pays parce que a parlé à
l'industrie rmc et ça change et je dois
dire je sais pas si c'est sous
l'influencé nouvelles personnes en mai
j'ai vu qu'il ya eu des changements
vraiment très positif
je dis donc ça c'est un peu le nom moi
je créerai pas du tout une nouvelle
il faut juste les renforcer les doter et
les rendre vraiment plus fort et puis ça
les aidera ils seront peut-être plus
motivés galant parce qu ils font de leur
mieux
honnêtement j'ai que des choses
positives à dire sur les gens qui
travaillent avec nos mais
malheureusement ils peuvent ils ont des
limites qui ne dépendent pas de l'ecir
c'est très bien parce que si les
pâtissières je peux vous garantir que je
parle que du medtech tuerait pas une
société en france parce que le problème
c'est qu'on reçoit du cir très bien par
contre nous on embauche des gens qui sur
l'université qui connaissent pas du tout
notre domaine puisque a pas de société
donc les on perd un an de temps parce
qu'il faut leur montrer qu est ce que
c'est que le dispositif médical dont qui
avait pas de tir c'est très bien il y
aurait je pense qu'ils auraient pas de
medtech en france comme start up
donc voila et puis la machine dont
parlait la madame je me rappelle mundo
bon alors oui c'est très bien parce que
je fais si vous savez comment ça se
passe où trouver un coeur vous avez un
récipient ben obs il la personne est
morte sur la route six accidents de la
route en général c'est des jeunes filles
qui meurt il faut enlever le cup 8
possibles et en général on prend un
avion un jet privé on en est on
transporte le coeur dans une glacière
comme vous disiez donc ces machines là
permet de garder le coeur plus longtemps
et maximiser la chance du transplant
donc comme il ya déjà pas beaucoup de
coeur disponibles malheureusement ça
maximise les chances de transplantation
est de ne pas perdre les coeurs qui sont
malheureusement rendu disponible par la
mort de patients sur au tour sur la
route sans ces précisions
la seule source et donc oui c'est très
bien voilà qu'ils ont mais bon moi mon
mot vraiment c'est c'est une industrie
faux-pas faut pas avoir peur d'en parler
l'innovation santé il y en aura plus en
france parce que l'innovation c'est
complexe
on parle pas de développer un cathéter
ou une seringue qui coûterait 10 1
millions là l'innovation aujourd'hui on
est arrivés en 2020 a développé des
coeurs artificiels des systèmes de
diabétologie de mesurant télémonitoring
qui sont connectés en haïti bon c'est un
peu barbare mais aux pompes à insuline
et ça c'est des projets que des
centaines de murs l'innovation
maintenant c'est des choses complexes
donc c'est beaucoup de capitaux est bon
c'est un sujet très très et c'est une
industrie faut l'approcher comme
l'industrie et la vraie question de base
c'est est ce que la france pense que
c'est stratégique pour la france d'avoir
l'industrie de la santé et ma réponse en
mai tech ont biotech elle encore plus
éloquente la metex et 600 milliards de
dollars l'année
et d'industrie c'est 7% de croissance
on ne fait qu'acheter on a zéro pour
cent de parts de marché en france alors
que le pib de la france
ces 5 4% du pib mondial on est à 0 % sur
un marché aussi énorme
la question et les clairs alors pourquoi
faudrait il s'intéresser aux métèques
parce que toutes les idées en
cardiologie les trente dernières années
sont venus de médecins français et
malheureusement ils ont été phagocyté
par des laboratoires américains
je pense que le cas d'école il est assez
simple mais il faut une volonté
politique et surtout un plan stratégique
et ça ça fait dix ans que je le demande
l'ex-gouvernement les nouveaux mais bon
et j'ai dit les iphone je sais que
quelqu'un ait omis millet avec l'iphone
depuis qu'il est élu
l'iphone se 600 milliards on fera jamais
d'iphone en france on fera jamais
d'iphone
c'est trop tard par contre la santé le
on peut en faire ce que les
idées viennent de chez nous alors le
marqua chez eux alors je sais qu'il ya
des émissions je sais pas comment
s'appelle cash sur l'a2 là je pensais qu
là qu il faut arrêter la santé c'est un
secteur spécifique moi je parlerais pas
de lanceurs ariane je connais rien donc
je sais que la santé ça touche tout le
monde
mais le problème c'est qu'on a mis en
pâture aux gens la santé ont comparé les
vivres mais le marquage ce lieu c'est
pas des délinquants qui regarde les
dossiers et je peux vous dire que si
vous voyez le dossier de quart matt
certes on n'a peut être pas être
beaucoup de patients mais le dossier je
pense que il est c'est la moitié ça doit
le faire dix mètres cubes de feuilles et
donc oui les gens disent ont ils ont
étudié pendant deux ans alors le
marquage que contrairement à ce qu'ont
montré des gens on peut pas donner un
marquage chez eux un sac pour
transporter les anges contrairement à ce
qui a été dit dans la presse donc le
marquage ce oui on peut le rendre plus
compliquée mais à ce moment là vous
savez il faut je prendre un cas un cas
d'école qui malheureusement nous a
échappé c'est la valve aortique
percutané est une idée française est
devenue maintenant le plus gros succès
cardiologie des 20 dernières années qui
est malheureusement été acheté par un
laboratoire américain
alain cribier on en parle partout il a
fait les patients en france ils sont
morts et donc il est parti au canada
ils n'ont laissé continuer ce qu'en
france on l'avait arrêté et après il a
été racheté aux états unis
alors si vous devez vous faire opéré par
un chirurgien en général vous avez
demandé vous avez combien d'années
d'expérience dans il vous dit ça va être
la première opération est ce que vous
allez rester avec nous c'était vous
échangez d'hôpital alors la vraie
question est ce qu est ce qu il faut
permettre aux charges a qui n'ont jamais
opérée d'opérer c'est ça la vraie
question est bien malheureusement ça
s'appelle la courbe d'apprentissage et
ben c'est vrai pour les produits
également donc vous pourrez mettre
toutes les règles que vous voulez il
faut dix ans pour stabiliser une
technologie dix ans donc on découvre des
choses tous les jours
nous on les découvre et c'est un choix
et il ya c'est pour ça qu'il ya un forme
de consentement
donc on informe le patient des risques
etc détaillé et après c'est au patient
ensemble avec son médecin de prendre la
meilleure décision mais en effet le
risque existe et je pense que il faut
accepter ça archaic notre les nouvelles
générations n'acceptent plus parce que
bon on a vu avec l'aco vie la mort et
tout ça on n'accepte plus la maladie
mais c'est la vie donc si on veut faire
de l'innovation en santé
eh bien il faut pas et je pense que les
règles ont bien on peut toujours faire
mieux mais je pense que la barre est
déjà assez haute et je pense qu'il faut
juste accepter quelle part de risque en
vous allez vous faire opérer du coeur
bah y'a pas 100% de chances d'en sortir
indemne
[Musique]